You actually did
an interesting experiment.
Can you share something
about that with us?
>> Well, we called it the lessons
of the Kobayashi Maru
which is a Star Trek reference for
our audience.
In the Star Trek episode, it was
an unwinnable exercise and young cadet,
James T Kirk, was forced, or chose,
to cheat on an unwinnable scenario.
And he reprogrammed the computer, and
was able to succeed in that exercise.
So, we want to put students
in a similar scenario,
with the intent of deliberately forcing
them to take on adversary mindset.
And mind you, the people that we
did this were government employees
that typically work nine to five.
And they don't have this mindset.
But they embraced it.
What we asked them to
do was to take a test.
We gave them very little notice, and
we told them the night before too, and
that they were expected
to cheat on the test.
And if they were caught cheating,
then they failed.
They weren't supposed to study.
>> Okay, so cheating was allowed.
>> Cheating was expected, and the test
itself was the first 100 digits of pi.
So they had to recite
the first 100 digits of pi or
actually write them down.
It actually worked out really well.
I'll give you a couple of
examples of their creativity.
One of them created business cards,
well actually had a stack, and
came up the next day before the test and
was very proudly giving
us their business card.
The rest of the stack, it turned out,
had the answer written on them.
So this individual could have
walked around in front of us and
given one to every single student,
and given them all the answer.
He chose not to, but he could have
because he subverted our trust.
Another example was someone who,
we allowed students to have soda
cans on their desk and
they printed out the answer.
And put in on the side of the can and
when we would walk around, they would
put their hand over the answers, and
then check the answers
when our back was turned.
And my personal favorite was a student
who would take one of the books
from the course,
scanned in the back cover,
loaded it in Photoshop,
and ghosted in the answer.
Printed it out, trimmed it down and
used hairspray to tack it lightly
to the back cover of the book.
It was indistinguishable unless
you closely looked at it.
So they created a whole
entire false book cover.
But that's exactly what
we are looking for.
We wanted people to
think like an adversary.
It really comes down to trust.
Where do you place trust?
Find those trust assumptions and
subvert.
>> So in this case the proctor was
the security system in some sense.
So you were proctoring all this time
when they were taking the test?
>> Yeah, so during the test,
my colleague and I were proctoring it.
And what was very funny, and granted,
we weren't trying too hard
to catch them cheating.
As we'd walk around the classroom,
in front of us, we'd see the students
staring up into the sky considering
the 73rd digit of pi, and
behind us, we'd hear rustling.
And then I'd slowly turn,
behind me were students
contemplating the 67th digit of pi,
the 82nd digit of pi.
And then behind me I'd
start hearing rustling.
But it was really a good deal of fun,
they embraced it I mean, I could go on.
It was just,
the innovation was off the scale.
But I felt it was a useful and
fun exercise.
>> Absolutely.
I think security we say is all about
our assumptions and guarantees.
And assumptions have to be about
the nature of the threat you're going to
be dealing with.